Mordechai is directed by David Koepp and
stars Johnny Depp Gwyneth Paltrow Paul
Bettany Olivia Munn and Ewan McGregor
this movie is a spoof on old British spy
films and Mordecai plays a wealthy guy I
guess who has a knowledge of paintings
and art and so an inspector comes to him
about a stolen painting and then he has
to try to help him find it and basically
it's a slapstick comedy that makes fun
of British spy films and it's really not
that good which is sad for me to say
because as a filmmaker I've actually
enjoyed pretty much all of David kept
filming 'event seen this it's a really
good thriller with Kevin Bacon also a
Johnny Depp I enjoyed secret window I
think it's pretty underrated and more
recently Premium rush
I didn't mind I thought it was a
well-directed chase film and a lot of
fun I really don't know what was going
on in his mind though when he made
Mordechai because it's a film that is
sometimes funny sometimes well acted and
always really sleek looking it's not a
badly directed movie in fact there are a
lot of inspired moments throughout the
film in the way in which David Koepp
directs and I would say was around the
halfway point where I completely checked
out from the plot and stopped caring in
general the plot is so stupid and
scatterbrained that you can't really
latch on to it and I think David Koepp
and the writer kind of lost the sense of
the fact that all good slapstick
comedies still have a plot that you're
invested in you can have funny jokes you
can have good gags you can have Johnny
Depp and Paul Bettany doing some really
good work but it's not going to matter
if you don't care about anything in the
film and you can't even really follow it
let's talk about Johnny Depp okay he's
an actor I endlessly admire I think he
has immense talent I think he's a
brilliant performer but lately he just
has not been making good movies at all
and in this movie I can see what he's
going for he's definitely trying for
like a mix of Jack Sparrow his character
from Alice in Wonderland and maybe a
little bit of Edward Scissorhands throw
in there too and it just is not quite
working I wouldn't call his performance
an absolute disaster like some are
because there are moments in this movie
that I did genuinely laugh but they're
so few and far between that the entire
thing kind of feels like Austin Powers
gone wrong I would say
best character in this film is actually
Jacques portrayed by Paul Bettany who's
basically Mordecai's bodyguard he's by
far the funniest character in the movie
and he has all of the best moments his
wife played like one of Paltrow is like
this presence that's always overwhelming
him that's very controlling and
everything and we're comedy could be
reap from that it just comes off as the
really annoying wife who won't let him
do anything they don't go for any of the
possible comedic situations that can
come of that and they just make one of
Paltrow really annoying there's also an
endless barrage of characters in this
movie and it's very hard to follow who
is who and what's going on and it's one
of those movies that it's trying so hard
to be fast and witty but it just comes
off as convoluted and the film is also
trying to be more adult which is
refreshing
but the slapstick humor doesn't really
mesh with that so look there are
positives about this movie Paul
Bettany's character I thought was pretty
entertaining there are moments where
Johnny Depp does a really good job in
this movie although the performance
doesn't quite work as often as it should
but I think a lot of that is due to the
really messy plot and the fact that
after a while you stop caring about
what's going on in this movie I'm gonna
give Mordechai a c-minus I think it
could have been a lot worse in the hands
of a less capable director but it also
could have been considerably better guys
what are your thoughts on Mordechai if
you did see it I'm guessing you didn't
because I was the only person in the
theater thank you so much as always for
watching guys and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
Oh